i don't know how you got back but you
made a big mistake coming here oh
contrermo frere
the mistake was thinking you'd won i get
it
i don't think you do but you're about to
and so will that idiot sheriff in his
right hand
and your little dog too
[Music]
who are you
where are my manners
sonic
meet
knuckles
my new bff ae
bestest friend forever and ever
fear not citizens
i am the hero you need and deserve
okay
let's do this
people connected with sonic in such a
great way on the first film so i'm very
excited to go on a second sonic
adventure mind if i drive
it's great to step into a sequel
the audience just jazzed to see the next
one time to go for a ride
everything's been elevated
it's so fun to dive into the mythology
and to give the fans more of what they
want
papa's got a brand new stash
the bigger the ego the bigger the
mustache
it's not big enough as far as i'm
concerned
it is really exciting that we have our
main cast back in
[Music]
so help me thomas okay sorry sorry we
have some new characters we have tails
oh lord there's two of them now
we also have the ultimate match for
sonic sonic
meet knuckles you're no match for me
i can't wait to show the fans the
knuckles character for a guy named
knuckles you are really bad at punching
it just gets bigger and better there's
more action
and more mischief hey you got a little
something on your
ability
return to sender
i was really excited to be a part of the
sonic world never thought in a million
years that i'd ever be a part of that
oh great the winter soldier
you